ja okay es tut mir wirklich leicht
übertrieben also es tut mir total leid
ich wollte ich nicht so anstrengend ich
meine sie selbst dafür dass so viele
knoten hindurch was gesagt und jetzt
willkommen beim neuen video jahren hatte
ich hoffe euch geht's gut ich weiß nicht
ob man das in der kamera sehen könnt
aber es hat einfach übels geschneit hier
in köln ja weil ich kurz sagen ich mag
schnee auf jeden fall und ich freue mich
immer wenn es schneit so leute bevor wir
mit dem heutigen video anfangen muss ich
sagen also passend zum thema wird wieder
was verlost ich habe mir gedacht da ist
in diesem video mädchen geht verlosen
wir auch was für mädchen und zwar haben
wir hier den jc die platino ich weiß
aber noch nicht ob es ein glätteisen
oder lockenstab ist ich kenne mich damit
nicht aus oder beides gleichzeitig ja so
die das ganz aus das ist wirklich das
beste glätteisen der welt kostet 260
euro globisch das einzige was sie machen
müssen um an der verlosung teilzunehmen
abonnent sein
das video leiten und so viele kommentare
schreiben wir wollen schreibt einfach
eure gedanken in den kommentaren oder
irgendwas keine ahnung hast allen
kommentaren wir dann halt irgendwie
gewinnen
also können praktisch auch 5000
kommentare schreiben oder das schon viel
damals noch für den dezember übrig eine
sofort kamera zwei paris eine
playstation 4
ein iphone und die action cam es gibt es
dann halt ist auch in den nächsten jahr
aber auf jeden fall alles vor
weihnachten also wir haben doch heute
schon jetzt wenn wir aber an mit dem
heutigen video und zwar geht es heute um
zehn mädchen ihr kennt wahrscheinlich
meine cds videos habe schon öfter mal
richtig gemacht hat muss allerdings dazu
sagen dieses videos sehr sehr sehr
spontan entstanden wir haben gedacht
elcom lassen video machen was machen wir
und dann bin ich halt irgendwie auf das
thema gekommen oder die mädels ich hoffe
ja trotzdem spaß und ich wünsche euch
jetzt ganz viel spaß
let's go
und war es auch der den ganzen tag
arbeiten oder unten mittag chefin habe
ich auch schon mal bei euch auch sogar
ich kann sie dann wieder einschlafen
jetzt ja wenn wir eine gute idee oder
das war jetzt endlich los feiern gibt
sagt volkelt aufgabe die ich jetzt noch
irgendwie und die faulen
okay okay ich bin ich ja keine ahnung
hätte ich doch nichts für douglas von
den wänden einfach und weil er dem
verein und der bassist der bild ja auch
die zuckerrüben
aber es ist das lern- und verlieben
doch nicht nur das na ja die kommen
wieder ist bei youtube
ich muss anzugeben also ab und uns die
videos schaffen es gar nicht dass hier
ein echt so krass gut aussieht muss
jetzt im quo zu klären und mein gott ich
auch die fan girls dich nicht so an ja
ich bin mit zahlreichen toten in dein
herz
ja ich bin halt nur ausmachen haus nicht
auszureichen
sekunden später hast du mir leid ich
hätte dich nicht so an passende ja hast
du mir auch echt voll leid dass ich dich
so angetrieben haben die tücken mit sich
gezogen
habt ihr eine chance vor
also ich bin allerdings hat bisher
überhaupt so könnte mein kleiner bruder
sein
ja ok kaum noch
alter gucken was die finanzaufseher to
maine quasten mir gekommen
das sind fangen ja auf jeden fall
natürlich doch noch zeit
ist ja sonst
die dinge und ich habe ja letztlich
schon erzählt so dass ich voll das
gefühl dass man freut mich betrübt ja
dann hab ich gestern so auch instagram
guckt und hab gesehen dass er ein bild
von ella geleitet war und cousine von
jesse nicht von jackson nicht noch und
ich habe jetzt einfach so sehr das
gefühl dass sie sich versucht überall an
jesse wieder ran zu machen denkst du
wirklich dass er das so nötig hat
einfach über 1000 baby wieder
ranzukommen es war echt ein bisschen
umständlich und echt ja glaube ich
eigentlich sagt schon mal unsere
beziehung nach der schon seit längerem
nicht mehr so und ich meine dies halt
nicht gleich zu haben
siehst du hast viel besseres verdient
glaubt mir also wirklich erst so unten
durch die gossip girls drehte ich eine
wette verloren hat ist möchten und was
ist hier auch was halb mensch halb tier
ist wie sich so schon und jetzt ist das
möchtegern müller oder was
okay leute ich bin gerade mächtig wird
macht noch mal außer dürfte den
wenigsten ok mit dreh dich mal türken
bitte nein kann ich jetzt hier raus
ziehen wir die schuhe ab die mama ich
kann man darum laufen
nein nein und das gemisch das möchte der
muss ja jetzt tut mir wirklich leid
übertrieben also es tut mir auch total
leid wollte ich echt nicht so anstrengen
ich meine kannst dir selber nichts dafür
dass du so viele knoten haben sollten
jetzt war ja heute das was mit dem video
wenn es euch gefallen hat was noch nach
oben da wie gesagt nehmen vielleicht
teil beim locken glätteisen gewinnspiel
was auch immer und wir sehen uns schon
morgen wieder was machen wir jetzt also
wir bauen jetzt einen schneemann der
aussehen soll wie ein youtube
das kann man online haut rein auf jeden
fall der schneemassen große 2